ich habe eine wohnung gekauft dem
einzigen grund sie komplett zu
renovieren und daraus meine traumwohnung
nachdem ich euch gezeigt habe wie ich
sie gekauft habe die community
entschieden hat diese umgebaut werden
soll und wir im letzten video alles
rausgerissen haben geht es dieses mal
endlich an dem wieder aufbauen das
dachte ich zumindest bis uns eine böse
überraschung hinter einer der wände
erwartet hat die potenziell das gesamte
projekt bis dezember auf eis legt ich
wünsche euch viel spaß mit folge 4
[Musik]
[Applaus]
bevor wir aber anfangen konnten zu
arbeiten müssen wir erst mal die ganze
scheiße aus dem letzten video beseitigen
wirklich kubikmeterweise abraum also
betonplatten aus den wänden fliesen aus
dem bad laminat vom boden ich wusste
nicht dass so viel kram in so einer
kleinen wohnung platz findet alles
runter getragen alles ins auto gepackt
und diverse male zum wertstoffhof
gefahren
krumme dinger jetzt das alles fertig war
von mir endlich anfangen zu arbeiten
naja und vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren um keines der folgenden
videos aus diesen projekten zu verpassen
und mich und diese gesamte projekt hier
kostenlos zu unterstützen erstmal habe
ich mich mit meinem sak betrieb des
vertrauens also seine heizung klima
zusammengetan und wir haben gesprochen
was überhaupt in diesem bad möglich ist
das ist eben eine bestands wohnung und
es gibt nur begrenzte möglichkeiten an
denen wir uns irgendwie entlang hangeln
muss das ganze war auf den ersten blick
ziemlich ernüchternd ich wollte
unbedingt eine bodentiefe dusche im bad
und mir wurde gesagt hey das ist mit
ziemlicher sicherheit nicht möglich weil
wir nicht genug gefälle in die wohnung
gekommen weil unter dem estrich
potenzielle heizungsrohre liegen könnten
und so weiter dazu wollte ich eigentlich
unter putz gästen also das quasi das
wasserreservoir für die toilette hinter
der wand verschwindet und auch das war
nicht die beste lösung weil es deutlich
mehr platz im bad wegnimmt als würde man
eine andere lösung nehmen und ich dachte
schon oft jetzt habe ich angekündigt
dass das hier alles so mega luxuriös
wird und jetzt ist es bei mäßig gar
nicht möglich so wie ich mir das
vorgestellt habe also erstmal angefangen
alle wände auf gemacht und geschaut was
uns dahinter erwartet ich habe
tatkräftige sak unterstützung gefunden
ich habe natürlich den vorteil von
reichweite und das in der story gefragt
und es hat sich tatsächlich eine kölner
firma erbarmt links dazu sind in der
video beschreibung aber wie gesagt bei
wasser und bei electric dieses
vielleicht ganz flau sich profis dazu zu
holen es geht um dichtigkeit das muss
alles vernünftig alle schritte müssen
vernünftig gemacht werden und wenn es
damit am ende irgendwann probleme geben
sollte dann ist die scheiße richtig am
dampfen also schaue ich als erstes mal
ein bisschen zu helfen da wo ich helfen
kann und er freue mich einfach daran
dass es weitergeht und was ich zu diesem
zeitpunkt noch nicht wusste der satz
sollte sich zu 100% bewahrheiten und ich
sag nur soviel es war absolut richtig
sich profis dazu aber erstmal
durchlauferhitzer abbauen und versuchen
zu verstehen wo welche leitungen hergeht
wohnung ist vom 1971 also über 50 jahre
alt und mit ziemlicher sicherheit sind
die leitungen genauso aus warte mal auf
diese idee sind wir auch gekommen als
wir in der wohnung und es ist ziemlich
groß aufgefallen um das jetzt besser
begutachten zu können und damit der
probe die freie sicht haben wir jetzt
die waren auch noch weg das habe ich
eigentlich gar nicht geplant und wir
hoffen mal dass uns nichts zu schlimmes
hinter der band erwartet
[Musik]
weiter
das ist so ziemlich das schlechteste was
uns hätte erwarten können aber das hier
ist der ist-zustand einmal die ecke und
bist ein problematischer noch hinter der
muffe dahinter an und für sich kein
riesen ding also hier tobt jetzt nicht
aktiv raus was das ganze aber
problematisch für das komplette projekt
macht all das hier gehört nicht mir
quasi das gehört der hausgemeinschaft
und das bedeutet ich muss nicht mit der
hausverwaltung in verbindung setzen muss
das mit denen abklären also das ist
richtig scheiße also wirklich ein
problem das den kompletten zeitplan für
dieses projekt für diese wohnung
auseinander nehmen weil diese leitung
gehören zum haus nicht zu meiner wohnung
sie sind gemeinschaftseigentum und
gehören quasi allen eigentümern des
hauses zu einem gewissen anteil das
bedeutet alle können gemeinsam darüber
entscheiden wann diese leitungen wie
erneuert werden und es kann sich
potenziell um tage wochen oder monate
handeln dass dieses ding richtig
auseinander fliegt und das komplette
haus voll mit wasser läuft was natürlich
überhaupt nicht im sinne von irgendeinem
der eigentümer ist deswegen kann der
hausverwalter in bestimmten fällen in
akuten fällen auch selber entscheiden
und man muss dann nicht ist dezember auf
die nächste hauptversammlung warten wo
darüber abgestimmt wird der
hausverwalter der im übrigen super nett
und mega engagiert war hat sich nach 20
uhr noch mit mir getroffen um das
problem anzuschauen und was seine
einschätzung war wieder jetzt weiter
vorgegangen wird das erfahrt ihr später
im video es sogar so unheimlich viel in
diesem projekt zu lernen weil das ja
eine meine hauptmotivation für mich und
diesen kanal ist und deswegen freue ich
mich umso mehr dass geld der partners
heutigen videos ist es gilt jetzt eine
online plattform die es euch ermöglicht
von überall aus übers handy über den
browser über den fernseher mit apple tv
podcast sogar neues geld zu lernen oder
bestehen das gilt es zu verbessern es
gibt tausende online kurse zu
verschiedensten themen so dass für jeden
etwas dabei ist voll kochen über
unternehmertum bis hin zu 3d design ist
wirklich alles dabei das angebot an
deutschsprachigen kursen wächst stetig
und es gibt einige coole skills zu
lernen wie zb iphone fotografie dies
euch ermöglicht mit eurem täglichen
begleiter bessere fotos zu machen und
einfach das maximum rauszuholen auch für
mich ist das super wichtig weil ich
natürlich unheimlich viel mit dem handy
arbeite allem eine instanz sind mit dem
handy gemacht und auch in diesem video
habt ihr schon einige aufnahmen vom
iphone gesehen aber auch alle
englischsprachigen kurse sind deutsch
untertitelt wodurch geben beispielsweise
die möglichkeit habt sketchup zu lernen
was das programm ist mit dem ich die
wohnung designt habe in der ich hier
gerade stehen das design ist zwar noch
nicht umgesetzt aber ich habe es
geschafft schon design das beste ist
aber die ersten 1000 leute von euch kann
das gilt für 30 tage komplett kostenlos
testen und ausprobieren also seid
schnell klickt auf den ersten blick
einer video beschreibung und sichert
euch einen kostenlosen pro monat ich
danke vielmals dass sie mich und diese
gesamte projekte unterstützen und
dadurch auch möglich machen und euch
viel spaß weiter mit dem video außerdem
gab es ein kleines geschenk war in der
wand gefunden haben dynamit nobel und
das wollen wir uns jetzt mal gemeinsam
ansteht 100 kartusche nur für bolzen
setz werkzeug kaliber 6,3 mm ein viertel
zoll starke ladung einfach
patronenhülsen bzw patronen sind ja
nicht nur hilfen denke dass die
irgendwie so ein hammer werkzeug oder so
reinkommen
kleines geschenk also die neuen
anschlüsse für dusche wc und waschbecken
zusammengebastelt und in den wänden
platz für sie geschaffen also alte
leitung drei stämmen und raus flex
dann wurde mir gezeigt wie man im
modernen bauten zu wasserleitung verlegt
das ganze ist ziemlich cool und deutlich
deutlich einfacher als früher früher
musste für alle leitungen gelötet werden
heute presst man sie was deutlich
schneller einfacher und komfortabler ist
also im prinzip steckt man wirklich zwei
vorgefertigte teile ineinander und eine
maschine dran die dafür vorgesehen ist
die drückt diese klemme zu und wir sind
fertig
neue leitungen liegen überall jetzt
schon im bad aber nur bis zum ersten
haupt wasser absperrventil also diesen
haben wo man in seiner wohnung für die
wohnung das wasser abdrehen kann weil
dahinter ist es dann
gemeinschaftseigentum und dahinter ist
es am rosten der hausverwalter erklärt
gerade mit den eigentümern über und
unter mir wie es weitergehen sollen das
ding ist die situation ist wirklich akut
also man kann nicht sagen wann es da
kracht und wann das wasser dann wirklich
daraus läuft deswegen ist es im sinne
aller dass die leitungen
schnellstmöglich gemacht werden und bei
mir liegen sie jetzt eben frei also im
prinzip spricht alles dafür dass wir
jetzt schnellstmöglich eine lösung dafür
finden und neue leitung und die wand
ziehen wir brauchen jetzt da eine
antwort sonst kann es erstmal nicht
weiter eine positive sache hat das ganze
aber wir haben das jetzt hier offen und
wir sehen dass hier am abfluss ort eine
muschel ist an die wir dran geben können
oder sehen gleichzeitig dass hier die
heizungsrohre laufen was mit ziemlicher
sicherheit bedeutet dass die heizungs
boge hier
irgendwo am boden her reden hier in die
hand so was wiederum bedeutet dass die
heizungsrohre nicht unter dem estrich im
fußbereich sind und das ist die perfekte
voraussetzung um möglichst bogen tief
oder zumindest sehr nahe dran zu kommen
mit der duschwanne was deutlich besser
ist als gedacht weil ich jetzt schon
fest davon ausgegangen waren dass wir
sieben acht cm hoch müssen mittel sieht
jetzt aber deutlich besser
[Musik]
sie hier gerade seht ist unheimlich
wichtig war ihm schon erklärt warum weil
wir jetzt aus finden konnten das
heizungsrohre nicht darin jeder
zentimeter dem wir herausholen hilft uns
eine dabei dass wir die stufen in die
dusche nicht hören das ist richtig geil
und viel besser als gedacht wenn wir
gerade mal ein bisschen rohr aus dem bad
freigelegt da geht nicht mehr so
besonders viel wasser durch
manche stellen gehen klar andere sind
deutlich schlechter
es ist schon sehr gut dass wir das
wirklich einmal komplett machen das hier
war das zu was für das ohr stecken es
hat noch funktioniert aber es ist kein
millimeter also irgendwo wahrscheinlich
ein millimeter aber eigentlich ist
dürftig und durch die so sehen
vermutlich eure leitungen aus wenn der
70er jahre lebt in dem nichts mehr
gemacht und genau hier habe ich auch
wieder gemerkt wie wichtig das war das
projekt größer anzugehen also wirklich
von grund auf die wohnungen umbauen neu
bauen zu wollen und einmal alles zu
kontrollieren hätte ich jetzt für viel
geld neue parkett reingelegt hätte die
wände neu gemacht hätte alles neu
verputzen lassen neue spachteln lassen
neu streichen lassen und in dem halben
jahr hättest ein rohrbruch gegeben dann
hätte das alles wieder aufgerissen
werden müssen und ist wer wasser im haus
gewesen also wirklich unheimlich wichtig
dass wir uns dafür entschieden haben das
von grund auf einmal richtig zu machen
nach dieser doch sehr anstrengenden
woche nerven aufreibenden etwas
negativen woche für mich um das projekt
gab es dann aber noch mal ein absolutes
highlight mein installateur des
vertrauens oliver marx hat ein bisschen
rum telefoniert und andere haag
angerufen mit denen er gute erfahrungen
gemacht hat und wir haben uns mit allen
gleichzeitig in der wohnung getroffen
also wir haben jetzt einen tischler der
sich um alle einbau möglich wir haben
einen absoluten experten im bad der uns
dabei hilft das bad noch deutlich
luxuriöser zu machen das wird megageil
und wir haben ein elektroinstallateur
den nicht nur elektro macht sondern
unsere komplette lichtplanung also es
wird jetzt richtig richtig geil wenn wir
denn irgendwann mal weitermachen dürfen
und die hauptwasserleitung repariert ist
wenn er das ganze nicht verpassen wollt
wenn ihr sehen wollt wie die
einbauschränke reinkommen wie es mein
bart weitergeht wie es mir der
hauptwasserleitung weitergeht und so
weiter dann vergesst nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren wir sehen uns nächste woche
sonntag zur nächsten folge wieder und
hoffen dass bis dato unsere wasser
unsere was unsere wohnung nicht komplett
unter wasser erstickt couscous kurs